resultados reflejan que la señora
xiomara castró ganó las elecciones a
pesar de en el consejo nacional
electoral de honduras no oficializado el
triunfo de la candidata de izquierda así
lo daba a conocer al presidente de esa
nación juan orlando hernández y desde ya
he conformado un equipo de transición
que facilite al nuevo gobierno asumir
labores en tiempo y forma las
declaraciones del mandatario saliente se
dieron a conocer mientras los resultados
electorales arrojan una ventaja de 15
puntos de xiomara castró sobre su
competidor cercano nazi rías cura más
del 60 por ciento de actas escrutadas a
su familia asfura reconoció su derrota
en una visita a su contraparte país
necesita reconciliación unidad para
lograr la armonía y el trabajo que es el
camino que nos llevará al desarrollo que
todos anhelamos la candidata por el
partido libre es la esposa del ex
presidente manuel zelaya quien dejó
saber su parecer sobre el panorama
actual en el país
honduras se ha convertido en estos 12
años en casi un cementerio de
calamidades y tragedias grandes zelaya
fue derrocado en un golpe de estado en
el año 2009 y es el actual líder de la
tolda política de la aspirante
presidencial xiomara castró sarmiento
cortas y un periodo de 12 años del
partido nacional en el poder
[Música]